maybe it started with the premiere of tv
shows like the walking dead
and the release of films like world war
z but there's no doubt that zombie
movies have been in the spotlight for at
least the past decade
ready to face the undead these are a few
of the best zombie films currently
available for streaming on netflix
the french canadian film ravenous or
laza for me begins in the rural
outskirts of quebec
where a few survivors have managed to
hang on after an outbreak of a
mysterious disease
turned people into bloodthirsty zombies
no one understands
the source of the infection all the
survivors know is that the infected
quickly develop a taste for human flesh
those who have managed to hang on are
inherently distrustful of one another
and any stranger who approaches will be
greeted with suspicion and a shotgun
the survivors realize that there's more
to the infected than an instinctual
drive to hunt human beings
the zombies have slowly been
constructing stacks of objects as if
they're preparing for some sort of
strange ritual what is the purpose of
these structures
and what are they infected waiting for
these questions will haunt you
throughout this suspenseful film as the
survivors try to figure out the answers
set during the mexican war of
independence in 1815
la dronas de almas or soul robbers
explores what happens when a group of
outlaws breaks into a family's compound
in hopes of finding valuable treasures
and they end up dealing with a situation
they never bargained for
the compound is occupied by one man his
three daughters
and their haitian servants the young
women seem harmless at first
but as it turns out they're quite
skilled when it comes to self-defense
not that they really need to do their
own dirty work unbeknownst to the
insurgents
the family compound is protected by
zombies suddenly they're facing a threat
that is even scarier than the war itself
if you're a fan of historical fiction
and zombie films la dronas de almost is
a perfect choice for streaming the
gorgeous cinematography and moody
lighting
help create a creepy atmosphere for a
suspenseful zombie film
five choads you go on might not be your
traditional scary zombie film
but it's definitely a lot of fun and
it's great for a couple of hours of
escapism
this indonesian flick will definitely
deliver with plenty of laughs and while
you should probably lower your
expectations as far as the special
effects go
it's definitely worth checking out for
the bombastic comedy elements alone
in five show which you go on yanto's
girlfriend is captured by a mobster and
he pulls together a bunch of his friends
who plan to fight to get her back
but mobsters aren't the only thing they
have to worry about the group has a
zombie outbreak to contend with two
the members of this ragtag bunch are no
superheroes but years ago
they made a pact to stick together and
help each other and now they've got to
fulfill that promise
the crazy fight scenes and colorful
cinematography helped five cho wajagawan
stand out from other
zombie films in the hindi zombie film
rise of the zombie
neil parker is a wildlife photographer
who spends too much time
thinking about his work and too little
time connecting with the people in his
life
he's begun to push people away and
eventually his girlfriend decides that
she has had enough
what's wrong everything about us
she breaks up with him and when she
walks out neil doesn't get the message
that he needs to work on his
relationships
instead he decides to give up on his
family and remaining friends and set out
into nature
he feels that he has no choice but
isolation and he no longer cares about
the life he is leaving behind
but as neil says goodbye to his old
world something strange begins to happen
once he has lost all of his human
connections he begins to lose his own
humanity too
a change occurs within neil and slowly
it becomes clear that his choice to give
up on everything and everyone that he
once held dear
has some serious consequences kl zombie
a malaysian zombie film
set in kuala lumpur tells the story of
nipiss
a pizza delivery boy who feels like he
doesn't have much going for him
aside from his passion for hockey one
day he's hanging out on a hill with a
few of his friends when his friend alif
is suddenly bitten by a duck
the group is shocked but another one of
their friends anna helps him get to the
hospital
and it seems like all as well but the
next day both alif and anna aren't
feeling so good
and it becomes clear that this was no
normal dog bite as it turns out this dog
was carrying a virus that zombifies its
victims
both anna and the leaf turn into zombies
and now the trouble really begins
the virus is spread to a group of school
children and more and more people
throughout kuala lumpur become
infected this particular breed of
zombies tries to curb their hunger with
normal food
but they can't ignore their instincts
now it's nipiss's turn to save the day
the girl with all the gifts is a
post-apocalyptic horror film based on
mike carey's novel of the same name
in which a parasitic fungus has turned
most human beings
into flesh-eating fast-moving zombies
called hungries humanity's only hope for
salvation
lies in a group of hybrid children who
still have a taste for flesh
but are mindless eating machines since
they can still think and reason the
children are detained at an army base
where they're taught by the kind and
patient helen justino
while being subjected to medical
experiments by dr caroline caldwell
melanie you're a clever girl
i think you know you think you can make
a cure out of me i can
caldwell intends to develop a vaccine
for the disease and believes that the
children are the key
a girl named melanie is particularly
gifted and just to know has taken her
liking to her
caldwell on the other hand the plans to
dissect her for the vaccine when
hungary's invade the base
the three of them end up on the run
together the adults have different
intentions for melanie
who just might be humanity's last hope
but can she be trusted
and if she's still human after all is
she willing to sacrifice her life for
caldwell's course
the south korean zombie movie alive
follows jun wu
a video game live streamer from seoul
who happens to be gaming in his family's
apartment when a disease breaks out that
turns he infected into zombies
after seeing a news broadcast about the
devastating new epidemic
june wu looks over his balcony to the
chaotic scene below when he witnesses
his newly infected neighbors attacking
each other he decides to barricade
himself inside the apartment
in a desperate plea for help he posed a
request to be rescued on social media
days later it seems like all hope is
lost june wu's family is dead and he's
lost internet and phone service
he has no running water he's running low
on food and there are no signs that help
is coming
suddenly he notices that someone in the
apartment complex across from him
is shining a laser point through his
window another survivor
you been is letting him know he's not
alone apart they couldn't have made it
but together
they just might have a fighting chance
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you